aude rigaud martinez par un merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
trois mille quatre cents lits
d'hospitalisation complète ont donc été
fermé en 2019 dans les établissements de
santé français dans le même temps 1500
places d'hospitalisation par cl ont été
créés vous qui êtes à nouveau en
première ligne face au regarde
l'épidémie comment est-ce que vous
réagissez face à ces chiffres
bonsoir va tout d'abord on va dire que
on a vraiment l'impression en tant que
personnel de pas avoir été entendu
savoir que le collectif interrogeant ça
fait deux ans que nous sommes là en
train de nous de nous battre pour avoir
plus de lits plus de moyens et il y
avait là la question de la
revalorisation des salaires qui
permettait de rendre attractif en fait
les postes et pouvoir recruter du
personnel à savoir qu'actuellement il ya
7500 postes rien qu'à l'assistance
publique qui sont à pourvoir et et on
pourra même si on le sait lui remettre
d'embauché 7500 autre personne j'ai du
mal à voir comment on va pouvoir
recruter du personnel
si l'hôpital n'est pas attractif on
pensait que le coc vidal est un petit
peu temporiser et on avait entendu le
président qu'il avait dit que quoi qu'il
en coûte
il a sorti des belles phrases de
communication quoi qu'il en coûte
on sait que par exemple la fermeture de
glee ça devient catastrophique dans
l'ensemble du territoire on voit que
finalement il ya vraiment une perte pour
les personnes de possibilité d'accéder à
des soins
lorsqu'il ya les hôpitaux ou des
services qui seront fermés en plus il
faut pas oublier que le celi qui sont
fermés actuellement il y à des services
qui sont fermées par manque de personnel
donc si on rajoute et on accumule tous
les lits fermés plus les livres où il
manque du personnel qui doit être fermé
par manque de soignants
ça devient catastrophique alors on
entend des douze alors le ministre de la
santé
olivier vers en jeu
chez nos confrères d'rtl dire vous ne
pouvez pas du jour au lendemain passé de
5000 à 10000 qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez
après il faut se donner les moyens à un
moment il faut savoir ce qu'on veut
certes on peut pas réouvrir des lits de
réanimation en claquant des doigts
mais par contre on peut former du
personnel ou qu' on peut essayer de
motiver les gens à vouloir se
spécialiser en réanimation
on peut on peut inciter les personnes à
avoir des promotions professionnelles
chose qui a été un petit peu mis de côté
depuis un certain temps c'est à dire
quand on aide soignant vouloir accéder à
la promotion officielle ça devient de
plus en plus compliqué on aurait pu tout
simplement ne pas fermer des lits
prendre des décisions à un moment à bras
le corps et ses dires on temporise on
voit ce qu'on peut faire parce que bien
ce bien souvent les lits lorsque l'on
parle de service et ça en loi avec le
collectif en local de gens c'est bat
pour conserver leur hôpital de proximité
pour conserver justement ces services et
finalement on s'en rend compte que rien
n'a été fait il ne sera pas entendue et
là ça devient catastrophique parce que
finalement qu'est ce qu'on doit faire
pour pouvoir être entendue mais
justement parce que finalement ce
malaise dans le milieu hospitalier il ne
date pas de la crise du coc vie 19 ça
fait des mois voire des années que il ya
des grèves des manifestations pour
alerter sur la population
comment est ce que vous comprenez que
finalement ces manifestations n'ont pas
inversé la tendance
on s'explique pas en fait c'est pour ça
que nous sommes encore en grève et on va
continuer à se mobiliser
je réponds qu est ce qu on vous répond
finalement depuis toutes ces années
en fait la réponse est très simple c'est
que nous nous travaillons il nous avons
vocation au service public et nous
sommes clairs dans notre mission ce
qu'on veut c'est pouvoir travailler dans
des conditions convenables pour pouvoir
accueillir les patients et ce qu'on veut
en fait c'est que peu importe le statut
socioéconomique et peu importe où vous
vous trouvez en france
puissiez accéder à des soins de qualité
et pour ça il faut mettre les moyens
la vision quand on a en face c'est
purement une vision économique et donc
on a on a un vrai problème de
communication parce que nous on parle de
patients on parle de l'art de soigner de
prendre en charge comme vous aimeriez
pris en charge vous ou l'un de vos
proches
et finalement on se voit à l'heure tu es
à un mur d'incompréhension avec des gens
qui nous parlent de statistiques et qui
vend aucun une vision de rentabilité et
ça c'est à dire plus que éprouvant
d'essayer de leur faire comprendre que
finalement un soin technique
si on le fait avec une personne âgée ou
une paire ou un enfant tout simplement
ça risque de prendre un peu plus de
temps il faut peut-être réfléchir sur la
qualité sur sur ce qu'on veut en fait
dans cette société est ce qu'on nous on
veut c'est rendre les soins et l'hôpital
humains aussi bien pour personnel mais
surtout pour les patients et finalement
on se rend compte que les pouvoirs
publics ont vraiment une vision un souci
de rentabilité et sans l a vu avec la
succession de les décisions politiques
qui ont été prises en compte notamment
la tarification à l'acte et des choses
un peu plus compliqué en fait on a
l'impression que même ça fait deux ans
que le collectif inter l'argent c'est en
grève
on a le collectif inter hôpitaux qui dit
qui est avec nous vous avez tous les
corporations enfin vous avez les iade
ibode vous avez la maternité vous avez
toutes les professions confondues
on est tous en train de crier que
l'hôpital ne va pas qu'il faut sauver
l'hôpital public et finalement on n'a
aucune aucune réponse qui nous
satisfasse
alors pour conclure il y a deux mois il
a eu les accords du ségur de la santé
alors je vais le rappeler
il prévoit 8 milliards de hausses de
salaires 15000 recrutement 6 milliards
d'investissements et 1,13 milliard de
reprise de dettes des hôpitaux le
ministre de la santé olivier veyrat
rassemblés mercredi à aujourd'hui les
parties prenantes pour un point d'étape
alors où est ce qu'on en ait des
engagements vous
ornementaux aujourd'hui bain
concrètement on attend toujours
voilà je crois qu'ils sont perspective
total des perspectives mais vous savez
ça fait tellement longtemps que quand on
entend beaucoup de choses et que
finalement concrètement notre quotidien
ne change pas il n'y a pas si longtemps
lundi dernier on a une réunion voilà on
pourrait citer les hôpitaux les urgences
les unes après les autres
il manque du personnel un exemple enfin
l'ag il ya 120 une nuit supplémentaire
pour les aides-soignants à l'hôtel dieu
il y en a 45 niveaux des infirmiers on
ne veut pas recruter c'est pas à défaut
de post de gens qui postulent c'est
juste que enfin il faut comprendre aussi
qui est l'hôpital n'est plus attrayants
les gens baisser les bras nous sommes
épuisés nous sommes fatigués de tout va
devoir dire les choses et de ne pas voir
finalement de changement parce que
finalement alors on a beau on est
toujours confronté à la même pas la même
problématique
il manque du personnel et ça on peut le
demander dans tous les services il
manque du matériel quand on a des hauts
quartiers dysfonctionne quand on voit
des patients qui sont hospitalisés sur
les bras car faute de lits il faut
comprendre que la problématique est bien
plus profonde que ce qu'on veut laisser
paraître
enfin quand vous êtes en province et que
vous n'avez pas accès à des services à
des spécialités
ça devient problématique quand vous
voyez nos collègues en ehpad qui ne
peuvent pas soigner la paix les
personnes aidées accompagné comme il se
doit et et avoir une quantité de travail
qui les épuise comprend il ya un
turnover il faut plus se poser la
question quand vous voyez que dans les
équipes d'urgence les gens restent trois
ans qui atteint 9 heures de trois ans
que l'exercice de la profession
infirmière ces cinq ans il faut se poser
les bonnes questions relativement le
métier n'attire plus le métier n'attire
plus effectivement on a bien entendu le
malaise au sein des personnels
hospitaliers aujourd'hui merci à vous
rodrigo martinez amara je rappelle que
vous êtes vice-président du collectif
inter urgence